die an kam der heute mein erstes
tutorial für euch ich hoffe meine videos
gefallen
nicht alle er ist eines der besten
lebewesen der welt er handelt im auftrag
der bundesregierung deutschland zur
bildung der menschen er ist unfassbar
toll es hier um die menschen zu retten
von dem pendant böse corp
da ist es nicht klug schulen abonnieren
kann macht es freunde das ist da wird
man ein besserer mensch von just ihr
seht es bereits im titel ein gelände
meine damen und herren wir schauen uns
heute die ersten videos von deutschen
youtube an
ich würde sagen da wir uns egal schon
auf den bestimmten deutschen youtube
kanal befinden klickt man einfach auf
videos damit wir einfach jetzt mal sehen
können was theoretisch mein erstes
hochgeladenes video ist also ich klicke
hier auf hinzugefügt am und mein erstes
hochgeladenes video ist minecraft
diamanten unter fünf minuten es hat
sogar eine million aufrufe
da muss man einfach mal knutschen
ich klicke da einfach mal drauf also wir
sehen dass hier schon sofort ich habe
das ja schon ein paar mal auf meinen
youtube-kanal selber angeguckt also ich
weiß was mich dort erwartet
es hat 33.000 likes ich hab's natürlich
selbst auch gelegt weil freunde
botschafter besser youtuber alles
schreiben nur es ist wirklich eine
stimme diese stimme was ist damit der
stimme los die stimme und so weiter und
so fort sie klingen jetzt einfach mal
auf play leute in diesem video zeige ich
euch einfach mal für ihr in einer
zufällig generierten welt in minecraft
eure ersten jahr würde sich so an als
hätte ich eine wäscheklammer auf meiner
nase und da wären wir dann auch schon
der zweite aber der zweite sache ihr
macht euch erstmal eine workbench und
zwölf stocker denken braucht entspannt
danke für deine tipps flug ab und er
sicherlich bemerkt ist dass ihr
nachsynchronisiert hat sich
glückwünschen wie die schon am anfang
gemerkt haben dankeschön dankeschön luca
echt mega lief das ist uns nochmal
erwähnen ist dass hier ist also meinen
zuerst auf youtube hochgeladene video am
12 08 2011 vor sechs jahren schauen wir
uns aber jetzt mal den kanal von max
hier an
irgendwie sieht bei max jedes zugleich
auch ist wir kriegen ja auch wieder
sortieren nach hinzugefügt am alte nach
neu sein erstes video war erstes video
mit kompletter mannschaft zweifel games
ach du heilige scheiße
bei eingang vatanparast alter spielen
hat damit bisher trotz auf youtube sei
keiner der eine folge die folgen die
alle die folgende alle diese uhren die
söhne beleidigt da die vollkommen fit
das ist auf jeden fall max erstes
hochgeladenes video das hat er zwei
jahre nach meinem ersten video
hochgeladen
mal schauen was hier noch so alles steht
übrigens kann ich auch richtig schreiben
nur leider war mein minecraft fenster zu
groß habe nicht gesehen dass ich ein
gegeben habe ja der lügt er kann
eigentlich gar nicht richtig schreiben
schauen wir uns doch mal das erste video
von julien the man also hinzugefügt alte
nach neu sein erstes video heißt angry
song you karaoke jucken training
wie kann es sein dass sein erstes video
so krass geil ist und die vom max und
mir einfach so scheiße
tras julien falls wir uns demnächst
sehen
respekt respekt respekt
als foul
als nächsten youtuber habe ich mir hier
beide palace rausgesucht
ich denke einfach mal auf ihrem kanal 12
millionen aufrufe
soviel hat mein ganzes leben ich mal wir
klicken wieder aussortieren alt nach neu
und das erste video von iris haare an
der kopfhaut flechten
hier sehen wir an der kopfhaut flechten
es geht also babys erstes video hier ist
harte kost schlechten ms hat tatsächlich
über zwei millionen aufrufe besucht mich
doch bitte auf facebook kommentare sind
auch einfach so standard kommentaren den
ersten videos alles einfach nur wer 2017
coup soll das licon und so aber bibi du
hast dich echt krass verändert nun
befinden wir uns hier auf dem kanal von
paletten und zwar klicken wir auch bei
puten einfach mal auf videos krieg mir
sortieren nach hinzugefügt alt nach neu
und dann sehen wir ein erstes video
let's play need for speed most wanted
part 1 hd bist du da
nicht so
zumal aussagen
hallo patrick
patrick patrick hallo patrick bist du
hier irgendwo nur wenige minuten später
bcf ich bin jetzt schon zwei minuten im
video der immer noch nicht geredet noch
etwas länger reichen nur wenige minuten
spenden freuen leute schön dass die
leute ein bisschen weiter also
vielleicht nimmt das ganze video noch
ein bisschen party rauf also ich will
einfach wieder auf das muss ich mal erst
mal ein bisschen an die soja morgen
herzlich willkommen zu meinem letzten
play need for speed most wanted mein
name ist blum eine schön dass hier
irgendwie den weg zu diesem video
gefunden hat schwerer stein ich ja dann
will ich einfach mal sagen versuchen wir
ja einer der most wanted von verhelfen
du fährst auf jeden fall gut auto gerade
als er ist auf jeden fall nicht so kalt
die beschreibung ist auch gut einfach
enjoy
als nächsten youtuber habe ich mir
sascha ecke eher unsympathisch
rausgesucht
das heißt wir kriegen auch hier
hinzugefügt alte nach neu sein erstes
video ist sascha stellt sich fordert
klicken einfach mal drauf
jetzt ist vor allem sascha als ist die
brieftasche leer muss ein youtube
channel her
das habe ich mir vor sechs jahren damals
auch gedacht als nächsten youtuber
schauen wir uns mal gran hinzugefügt am
alt nach neu sein erstes video von
sieben jahre let's play alles online
part 0
gut
ist es nicht part 1 bla bla ly herzlich
willkommen so arm
ein erstes video beginnen mit
bla bla
warum
waren wir alle früher so quin ski
unterwegs als nächsten youtuber habe ich
mich ihr gewinn zeit rausgesucht
weil ich gestern doch bei einem war wir
haben videos vorproduziert ist das das
ende von kräftig dagegen auf seinem
kanal und sie direkt in dem titel
rechtschreibfehler wir klicken wieder
auf alte nach neu und sehen sein erstes
video ist aus dem megaprojekt
das bin ich
das ist meins muslimen ich habe herzlich
willkommen auf einen neuen kanal mit dem
namen gewinnt zeit ihr seht jetzt gleich
die erste folge megatrend ich hatte
super viel spaß mit den ponys und wenn
die diakonie und ungarn
da wird eine super freund wäre sogar ein
abo dass die tage kommen noch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ihr müsst euch das vorstellen das video
fängt an er sagte dass meine neue kanal
abonniert alle dann kommt mit szene wie
simon danner und ich dreh wie in dem
haus von denner sind und irgendwie bei
explodiert und jetzt kommt's sonnen
intro und das intro besteht zu 90
prozent einfach aus dem text suche
dringend intro hersteller und dann
sondern verdutzt dass miley revue was
bist du für ein mensch wie du heißt auf
jeden fall den er macht peng minecraft
megaprojekt und wenn wir die kommentare
gehen sie mit gott da von mir war
blablabla ich muss hier nur das was
jetzt allerdings auch vom video meine
damen und herren wenn es euch gefallen
hat dass sich auf die ersten videos von
youtube einmal reagiert habe dann lass
gerne mal einen like da würde ich mich
sehr darüber freuen schreibt man in die
kommentare youtuber wenn ihr einen
youtube account habt und jetzt meine
damen und herren will ich sagen kommen
wir zu einer stelle hier im video die
tatsächlich relativ häufig in meinen
videos auftritt wo man sich tatsächlich
als normaler zuschauer denkt wow endlich
kommt dass das auto ja wohl die austro
das ist das was jetzt hier vom video
hier können jetzt hier in einen kanal
abonnieren oder
meinen stärken jetzt findet ihr zwei
andere videos und wenn ihr schon
abonnent seid könnt ihr auf die glocke
klicken dann bekommen die winde nach
richtigen
[Musik]